[Music]
statues are being toppled all over the
land
especially statues of the people in this
front
quad
[Music]
never mind that jefferson was the author
of the words that have been more
powerful to condemn slavery than
in history never mind that madison wrote
the document
that secured the liberty of us all in a
way for us to work together so we could
rule ourselves
over there's our war memorial it's the
oldest statue on the campus
and it's a monument to the people who
left here to fight in the civil war
several of them won congressional medals
of honor
we had a big part in the civil war of an
intellectual kind too
because there is nobody more
abolitionist
by theory and by practice by faith and
by reason than the founders of this
college
a bunch of christian patriots
classically educated
and you got to ask yourself the people
who are toppling these statues today
what have they done how can they look at
those people
with anything except sublime respect
look at them
look at the risk they took look at the
words they wrote
look at the sacrifices they made right
and today
we turn over their statues but not here
this place built by abolitionists was
built
in respect to those achievements
and that respect is a product of the
right kind of learning
that respect is the condition
freedom being able to continue in the
land
because you know we are required to act
now
we are in a mass in this country and
every fundamental thing is
up for question just like by the way
1776 and 1860
and we are blessed to have examples here
like james madison of how to comport
ourselves
and we will follow those examples with
the same determination they had
if they tear it down we will build it
back
[Music]